this episode is brought to you by
Verizon Wireless who's the most powerful
cold powered character in TV and film
will treat their movies like their video
evidence make real physicists study them
to get hard numbers on their exact
amounts of chill then have our iced out
heroes compete in challenges of our own
design to crown one the most powerful
this is power levels when deciding on
competitors three came to mind Elsa from
frozen frozen from The Incredibles an
Iceman from the x-men movies but while
Iceman is an omega-level mutant in the
comics
we need footage in future past he lasts
just one scene and in the original
trilogy he's an omega-level turd
so Elsa versus Frozone it is for our
challenges they'll have to ice slide
down the Hudson River freeze a Statue of
Liberty until it breaks then build an
ice sculpture monument to their
greatness whoever finishes each
challenge first gets a point most points
at the end of all three is crowned the
most powerful let's go when we begin
they both take off down the Hudson at
their top speed
let's analyze a clip of frozen to figure
out what that would be during this scene
he passes several cars whose length we
can estimate by dividing the distance
traveled by the time we can get his
velocity just under 86 miles per hour
I also use his ice to move the fastest
in the scene where she pushes Olaf and
her sister in circles we'll get the
distance by estimating the diameter of
the circle they make and computing what
the circumference would be then after
timing how long it takes her to travel
that distance will divide the distance
by the time to get her velocity but
she's pushing three people here and we
want Elsa so low speed so we'll need to
subtract the average weight of a
five-year-old girl and an object with
the density of snow the same size of
Olaf from the total weight of all three
the ratio of Elsa's mass to the whole
group lets us figure out how much faster
she'd go if she was only pushing herself
thirty four point five miles per hour
since the Hudson is 13 miles long we can
now easily figure out their total time
for part one frozen jumps out to an
early lead in the first part of the
challenge racing down the Hudson in nine
minutes to Elsa's 22 and giving him the
first point now that they've arrived at
the Statue of Liberty
they'll have to destroy it by using
their freezing powers to suck out all
the heat from the metal support
structure and make it
laughs generally metals become brittle
below negative 50 degrees Celsius and an
extremely cold temperatures it becomes
weak enough to break in this scene where
Elsa freezes her iron handguards off we
can see how long it takes her to freeze
metal to the point of failure first
we'll estimate the volume of the
handguards measure the time it takes to
become breakable then determine the
volume per unit time for which she can
turn metal brittle enough to break and
we'll do the same with frozen in the
scene where he destroys refluxes goggles
estimate the volume of the goggles
measure the time it takes for frozen to
do his thing then determine the volume
per unit time it takes him to make metal
brittle enough to break since we now
know their cooling rates we can look at
the volume of the skeletal frame of the
statue and estimate that if 10% of the
bottom supports turn brittle and crumble
away the center of mass will tilt over
its base and fall we then divide this
volume by each character's cooling rate
to get their time Elsa crushes froze on
in this challenge
finishing in two days to his 94 and
giving her point number two now they
need to build a giant ice sculpture of
themselves where the statue on stood to
see how fast they are at ice creation
well time the scene where else that
builds an ice castle from scratch and
estimate its volume and for frozen will
use the scene where he stops the Hydra
liner by creating a giant snowdrift
we'll take the volume of a similar
real-world yacht since he makes an
equivalent amount of snow then convert
it to ice by adjusting for the
difference in density between the two
side note when you freeze that much
water that quickly it would remove about
10 tons of TNT worth of energy so
Frozone is either containing that within
his body or it's best not to think too
hard about it the Statue of Liberty has
a volume of about 2,500 cubic meters so
dividing this number by their ice
creation rates gets us the time it would
take to make a statue of their own
greatness Frozone is more than twice as
fast in this challenge but unlike Elsa
there's no proof he has any artistic
ability so his statue might look kind of
janky still speed wins and his victory
in challenge 3 makes Frozone our super
chill overall winner how about a frosty
beverage as a consolation prize just for
what physicists call funsies let's check
how long it would take her to cool down
a lukewarm non-alcoholic beer we
determined your cooling power is about
45 times faster than froze ohms
since he can transform about 40 3,600
gallons of water into ice in one second
I also could cool off a beer in 48
nanoseconds meaning the crystallization
process from water to ice would move
through the drink at about 1% the speed
of light or as non scientists would say
like so fast
who knew also was such a beast I didn't
but she's still lost and the data
doesn't care about your feelings so let
us know who you want to see compete and
you can see them face off right here in
the next episode of power levels
this episode was brought to you by
Verizon Wireless
[Music]
you